[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 141 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mok Mandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie Warrick how you doing
Melanie so yeah it's good to be back in
the studio and this week we're gonna be
talking with haben Girma who is here to
talk to us about accessibility intact
Thank You Melanie for setting this up it
was a really great interview I'm a
little bit of a fan girl of hers because
I saw her speak and it just blew me away
and so I was really thrilled that she
not only came out to speak at next that
she also had time to come and join us
while we were recording there so that
absolutely absolutely
so before we get to the interview as
always we're going to start with our
cool things the week in it with our
question of the week and this week's
question mark has been able to find for
us which is going to be how do I perform
large-scale mutations in bigquery yes
which is a good question is a good
question because you put a lot of data
in bigquery you do and in order to make
any type of deleting or anything that's
going to be mutating there are some
limits so it helps give an understanding
of what this limits are but we'll get to
that later
so let's get started with our cool
things of the week you want to kick it
off I want to kick it off why not so I
think it's worth noting that sto the
service mesh basically they for
collecting logs traces telemetry
security and policy for distributed
applications basically it's the bit that
sits between all the services the way I
like to think about it it went 1.0
recently so it's declared ready for
production so if you've been looking at
e c.o you've been holding off a little
bit because it hasn't even hit 1.0 it is
now hit 1.0 so you can definitely check
it out there's a lot of interest and
popularity or honest oh you know one of
our colleagues Kelsey Hightower talks a
lot about it yes great we're probably
also mentioned that we also have
announced the alpha release of managed
SEO as well so definitely keep an eye
out for that - cool
we'll probably talk about that more when
beta comes another thing that we want to
talk about is that google has been doing
this effort to make Wi-Fi available in
different regions around the world and
so one of those areas in particular
they're doing Google Station which is
providing high quality Wi-Fi hotspots
across Nigeria the goal is that they
want to roll out 200 locations in five
cities by the end of 2019 and hopefully
bringing this to millions of people
which is something that they've been
working on for a while now in other
countries like India Indonesia Thailand
and Mexico well include a link as always
into the show notes and people can check
that out and see
you know what the effort looks like what
the timeline is and some additional
insights around what's being provided
yeah I'm really excited about this a
while ago episode 17 actually we did a
interview with here in Patel and dal
Humvee in Africa talking about some of
the the issues of the challenges they
face around infrastructure and how
reliable it is in that region so super
happy to see this also like coupling
that with some of the stuff that's been
going on like Google Co Maps Co YouTube
go basically these applications that are
designed to improve the experience when
there's an unstable or slower Network I
think these are really great endeavors
agreed just access to information this
is very important I know one of the
stats they mentioned in the blog is like
only 35% of Africans have access to the
web so yeah this is great so another
cool thing the week I think mark you
wanted to talk about intelligent yeah
big fan of IntelliJ been using IntelliJ
for a long time this is very specific
for those Java users that exist out
there but the Google cloud tools for
IntelliJ plug-in being able to access
services directly from your IntelliJ IDE
I thought this was kind of neat it is
neat it is neat so they have an example
in here of actually calling the
translate API directly from the IntelliJ
IDE and there are tools in there so you
can authenticate so like you know who
your account is and you can set up which
project you want which means if you want
to test out these kind of services give
them a bit of a demo give them a bit of
a spin and see how they work out it's
very easy to do from within the IDE so
yeah I love IntelliJ I don't actually
use it for job very much but for those
of you who do this probably would be
very useful agreed very much so
well mark I think it's time for us to go
speak with Hamid let's do it today we
are happy to have with us haben Girma
she this morning did talk where we're
doing this recording at next and she
just talked this morning on
accessibility in text so haben thank you
so much for joining us absolutely thanks
for having me here Melanie and hi mark
hi before we get started today and talk
about accessibility in tech can you tell
us about you and what do you do
my name is haben Girma and I'm a
disability rights advocate I teach
individuals and organizations how did
with access in mind one of the reasons I
do this is because I myself have a
disability
I'm deafblind I have limited vision and
hearing there are always alternative
techniques for accessing information and
I've been successful because I found
lots of alternative techniques and I
found communities that value alternative
techniques for example during this
podcast as Melanie or Marc speak their
words are being transcribed and output
into digital Braille and I'm feeling
their words in digital Braille and then
responding my voice and this technology
is an example of an alternative
technique and people with disabilities
have lots of different tools and
solutions that means what drove you to
become a speaker and a driven advocate
on this topic disability has the
potential to be an opportunity for
innovation and a lot of people don't
know that and I'm really passionate
about teaching organizations especially
those who focus on designing technology
to think of disability as an opportunity
for innovation for example email Vint
Cerf one of the founders of the internet
helped develop drone in the earliest
email protocols and this was back before
the internet existed as we know it today
back before Dopp individuals had a good
tool for communicating long distance
because we didn't have good access to
the telephone email wasn't we need to
communicate long distance and you could
understand a message without struggling
tier nowadays lots of people use email
hearing people deaf people and a lot of
the challenges people with disabilities
face from communication
to accessing print when you look for a
solution you'll end up finding a
solution that not only helps people with
disabilities but helps the greater
population and becomes the next big
thing so there are lots of hidden
stories out there that people don't know
about and I'm excited to teach people
these stories to them more designers
developers people who are in work in the
fields or technology can start investing
in accessibility that's so great and we
actually have a podcast on Vint Cerf so
it's funny that you mentioned him
excellent I didn't know you dude that's
that's perfect I know he's here at
Google right
yes yes so you talked a lot about tech
accessibility how do you define that
accessibility needs lots of different
things the goal is to reach as many
people as possible to build one product
one app when website that the maximum
number of people can use and they're
different elements to accessibility
there's visual accessibility making sure
blind people can access the service the
web content accessibility guidelines
helps teach how to make websites
accessible for apps there's Android
accessibility guidelines and for iOS
there's Apple accessibility guidelines
so if you're making something make sure
you follow the accessibility guidelines
so that it's accessible to the blind
community for the deaf community the big
thing is captions making sure videos
have captions so that deaf individuals
can access the audio content or for
podcasts including transcripts so that
people can access the contents of the
podcast those are some examples but it's
not the limit
there are lots of accessibility features
that are waiting to be built and if we
keep innovating we'll come up with new
solutions
that'll make even more things accessible
self-driving cars a lot of people with
disabilities are excited about
self-driving cars we're also worried
that we won't be able to use them so
we're we're hopeful that they'll be
designed with access in mind and future
technologies will be designed with
access in mind so lots of people can use
them when I saw you speak at black and
AI what resonated the most with me was
your point about how it should be one
technology for everyone not multiple and
that also goes to what you're saying
right now did you want to talk through a
little bit about that point that's a
great point some people when they think
about accessibility they think of a
separate special service so a separate
app for people with disabilities a
separate website for people with
disabilities separate is never equal you
might start out with good intentions and
intend for the two services to be equal
but down the line but one for people
with disabilities won't get updated as
often it won't have all the features and
it just becomes inferior separate is
never equal instead what we want is one
service one app designed for everyone to
use it it becomes easier for everyone
and some designers immediately think of
design problems because they're not used
to thinking about accessibility
constraints often spark innovation and
spark new ways of doing things if you're
not sure how to do something
google has an accessibility team so
folks here can ask people about
accessibility reach out to the
accessibility team or reach out to
disability organizations there are lots
of organizations in the Bay Area
there's the Saint Francisco Lighthouse
for the Blind nationally National
Federation of the blind or for top
services National Association of the
Deaf ask questions
reached out to the communities don't
make assumptions what challenges do you
normally see from companies who are
potentially looking to become more
accessible but haven't quite got there
yet a challenge people often cite is
resources and people often say that
accessibility is too expensive people
who say that are usually jumping to
conclusions and making assumptions
without doing the research I will say
that it does take more resources to try
to make something accessible later in
the stage of development rather than
thinking about accessibility from the
start for example if somebody builds a
skyscraper and then after they finished
building it realized wait we forgot
elevators and then they have to tear
down part of the building to add in
elevators that is more costly and
time-consuming compared to building an
elevator from the start
same concept it's easier to make
something accessible if you plan for
accessibility from the start as you're
designing the product or service and if
people have more questions you can ask
lots of organizations and lots of free
resources online for designing
excessively what are some of the subtle
biases that you've seen in their work
and the research that you've done one by
is the assumption that the disability
market is very small and it's a
charitable thing to design for
accessibility it's something to do for
charity and people don't realize that
the disability market is very large
there are 1.3 billion people with
disabilities around the world in the
u.s. 57 million Americans with
disabilities but the large market so if
you make your services accessible you
get to tap into that large market which
means more revenue more business
opportunities so it's good business to
invest in accessibility stop thinking
about it it's charity it's not charity
it's a great business opportunity have
you've got any great examples where
you've seen accessibility done really
well one classic example City of
Berkeley once upon a time the City of
Berkeley did not have accessible
sidewalks and advocates complained and
advocated to have full access to the
sidewalks and Berkeley put in curb cuts
so that wheelchair users can go on and
off the sidewalk and travel freely
throughout Berkeley leader parents with
strollers took advantage of the curb
cuts and they found that they could push
their their toddlers in strollers on and
off very easily
workers pushing things on wheels
travelers with luggage kids with
rollerblades lots of people ended up
benefiting from these curb cuts and this
concept of a disability accessibility
feature benefiting the entire community
is now called the curb cut effect and
you see it in lots of different areas
lots of people use elevators and it
benefits lots of people cap
benefit deaf people but captions also
benefit hearing people as well sometimes
hearing people are in noisy settings and
they can't quite hear what's going on on
their video so they'll turn on captions
so they can fully understand what's
going on in the video or maybe they
don't want to maybe they don't want
other people to know they're watching a
video and they want to be sneaky
so they'll turn off the audio and turn
on captions a marketing study my
facebook found that adding captions to
videos increases view time on average of
about twelve percent so lots of benefits
to including captions curb kind of
factors you see it in lots of different
places
I love captions I use them they're very
helpful for me actually exactly what
about you mark do you use captions I
don't my wife definitely does that
they're very helpful yeah I know you
gave us some great recommendations on
resources are there any additional
resources that you would recommend for
developers and designers to improve
accessibility design I wanna repeat
again that there are Android
accessibility guidelines for developers
tap into those and look into that and
for websites web content accessibility
guidelines if you're still not sure
there are lots of online resources you
can check in with the San Francisco
Lighthouse for the Blind you can check
in with the National Federation of the
blind and there are also accessibility
consultants you can connect with you're
welcome to reach out to me again my name
is haben Girma and my website is haben
Girma calm thank you I have an eye one
thing I want to leave on or at least one
of the last things I want to ask is you
did this wonderful talk earlier today
can you share with our audience a few of
the key takeaways that you shared with
the audience here
the key takeaway from my talk this
morning is that all the barriers that
exist are created by people they're
arbitrary they're not necessary at all
disability for example is never a
barrier the barriers created are created
by people and one example idea is how
Harvard
once upon a time used to deny access to
woman Helen Keller when she was looking
for colleges to attend couldn't attend
Harvard back then Harvard only valued
men and Harvard wouldn't admit women
over time
Harvard change society changed and now
Harvard has opened its doors to women
people of color and people with
disabilities so the barriers that exist
are created by society not disability
and as developers you have the power to
create tools and solutions that help
people rather than creating barriers so
this we're at a technology conference
here at next is there any particular
technological technological advances
that you've seen that you think are
gonna break down barriers in the future
for people with different abilities
self-driving cars have the potential to
break down barriers if they're designed
to be accessible
well wheelchair users be able to get in
and out of these cars independently will
blind people be able to drive these cars
independently how about someone with
arthritis so it really depends on how
they're designed we're excited but we're
also worried so please don't disappoint
us I think that's a wonderful point well
Kevin thank you so much for taking the
time to come and chat with us we really
appreciate it
yes thank you so much you're very
welcome
thanks Melanie and Mark and thank you
again humming for coming on the podcast
yeah we really enjoyed having that
interview for sure yeah and thanks as
well to her translator for coming and
spending the time with us as well and
making that whole thing possible agreed
well mark question of the week yes how
do I perform large-scale mutations in
bigquery this is an interesting question
I don't actually work personally with
bigquery that often so I learned a whole
bunch of stuff looking at this today
there is a blog post that talks all
about it strangely enough which is why I
ended up learning about it which is
lovely so bigquery you know it's our big
data query system where you massive
amounts of data querying over very large
datasets terabytes petabytes of data but
sometimes you want to edit that data
maybe it went in wrong maybe you want to
change it maybe you want to delete some
for archive purposes all that kind of
good stuff so bigquery does have a data
manipulation language that you can use
for like select statements merge
statements update statements acceptor et
cetera but the limit that you will hit
is that there are quotas about the
frequency of mutation that you can make
over the tables that you have this is
basically because we do store lots and
lots and lots of data and we do very
special things to do it essentially so
maximum number of combined update delete
and merge statements per day per table
is about 200 the maximum number of
combined update delete and merge
diamonds per day per project is about
10,000 you can definitely make updates
and there's no limit the amount of size
of data that you manipulate when you do
those manipulations so like a common
scenario might be where you might want
to update existing data based on new
information coming in through on a
periodic basis just be aware of those
sort of limitations so maybe you want to
do that sort of once a day over the
entire data set if you can rather than
doing multiple times per day just keep
those limitations in mind that will link
to the article which has other links to
other articles around like what the
quotas are unlike what's available and
what's not but yeah as long as you keep
in mind those quarters you should be
good to go agreed everything that's
going on with data in general this is a
key thing to be able to work through
check out that link alright mark where
are you going to be I'm gonna be at pax
dev and packs west so pax dev will be
starting August 28th so I should really
put my flights I will be talking about a
ghana's at PAX dev and then hanging out
with PAX West with all my game and
friends and cosplaying friends and all
the other good stuff Melanie where are
you gonna be what are you up to
so as we speak I'm actually in Vegas at
all the security conference
and besides and black hat and all that
this is my first time and this is
interesting
I'm excited for you yes me too cool good
outside of that I think that's most of
the conference's for me right now which
is great that is great I should mention
I will also be at Tokyo next in
September that'll be the thing I'm doing
afterwards so that'll be awesome as well
and I actually since you're gonna bring
up September will be at deep learning in
Taba in South Africa in September sweet
fantastic well Melanie thank you again
refer to joining me for yet another
episode of the podcast thank you thank
you all for listening and we'll see you
all next week
[Music]
[Music]